我們要來到就是台股一級散戶巨人節的神秘操盤室
可以看到線條除非有兩個助理之外
還有滿滿的螢幕
桌上還有一隻金雞另外10多塊的電腦螢幕上都擺滿的線圖
前陣子信息有開始轉弱
那國防概念股也開始轉弱
那資金找到一個出口就是記憶體漲價這個題材
記憶體因為本來就比較小的族群
所以相對來說它的漲幅比較客觀一些
台股傳奇交易者巨人節分享了台股資金流動的趨勢
原本被市场称作当冲网的他
考量到短线为纳量不足的问题
近几年九成的比重都放在长线波段布局上
从产业面切入寻找强势族群
以及衍生出的供应链题材
拼的是获利率
我自己看一个族群的强势一定是用涨幅来看
那跟市场的热度来看
像我们举个例子
前阵子的因为在炒AI的server规格的提升
所以前阵子一开始炒的是波线部
现在AI server规格持续的升级
那像下一代的AI Server
可能會使用M9等級的CCL那這部分的話是我們還會持續看好的持續看好今年最大的主流仍然是比較上游的CCLPCB族群以及國防產業
不過台股頻頻創下歷史新高
佔上了兩萬六千點大關
高檔震盪
台積電也突破了一千三百元新天價
是否要居高思維先落袋
據元杰認為
還是要看當初進場的理由
如果你是一個看比較長期的投資人
那這部分應該是不急著去挺立
因為它是一個產業的趨勢
或是我們現在以光通來講好了
光通現在從過去的800G
現在提升到1.6T
那這件事情也還沒實現
或是你本來就只是因為技術分析
或是單純只去追搶的話
那相對來說
現在應該是一個蠻好的獲利了結的時機
不因為大盤未接停力
居然接改做長線波段
主要以目標價為進出場依據
只要趨勢不變就續爆
可以做到3.5年
持续在古海中寻找下一只成长股
记者110 林秋强 台北太坊八岛